aquí tenemos algunas manzanas y algunas
naranjas y queremos pensar en que es una
razón cuál es la razón de manzanas a
naranjas manzanas naranjas y para
explicar lo que estamos hablando digamos
que una razón nos indica la relación
entre cantidades de dos cosas diferentes
entonces hay un par de maneras en las
que podemos especificar lo podemos
contar literalmente el número de
manzanas 1 2 3 4 5 6 tenemos 6 manzanas
y podemos decir que las razones 6a y
luego cuántas naranjas tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
esto es 6 a 9 la razón de manzanas a
naranjas es 6 a 9 y podríamos usar una
notación diferente
podríamos escribirlo de esta manera y se
lee como la razón 6 a 9 pero no tenemos
que conformarnos con esto porque una
forma de pensar en
razones o proporciones especialmente si
estamos pensando en manzanas a naranjas
es cuantas manzanas tenemos para un
cierto número de naranjas y cuando
pensamos de esta manera los dos números
6 y 9 son divisibles entre 3 de modo que
si dividimos 6 y 9 entre 3 si dividido 6
entre 3 es 2 y 9 dividido entre 3 es 3
entonces podemos decir que la razón de
manzanas a naranjas es 2 a 3 o podemos
usar esta anotación 2 a 3 ahora esto
tiene sentido bueno fíjense dividimos
este grupo en 3 si dividimos este gran
total en tres grupos
un grupo dos grupos y tres grupos
iguales vemos que en cada uno de estos
grupos para cada dos manzanas tenemos
tres naranjas para cada dos manzanas
tenemos tres naranjas para cada dos
manzanas tenemos tres naranjas
así que una vez más la razón de manzanas
a naranjas para cada dos manzanas
tenemos tres naranjas pero también
podemos pensar en esto de otra manera
también podemos pensar en cuál es la
razón de naranjas a manzanas razón de
naranjas a manzanas y aquí esencialmente
intercambiaremos los números cuál es la
razón de naranjas a manzanas aquí arriba
dijimos que la razón de manzanas a
naranjas es 6 a 9 o 2 a 3 las cuales son
razones equivalentes y aquí estamos
diciendo la razón de naranjas a manzanas
entonces vamos a intercambiar los
números aquí tenemos 9 naranjas para
cada 6 manzanas así que podríamos decir
que la razón es 9 a 6 o una razón
equivalente para cada tres naranjas
vamos a dividir esto entre 3 para cada
tres naranjas vamos a tener dos manzanas
fíjense que es exactamente lo mismo que
tenemos aquí arriba pero donde teníamos
manzana sana
la razón era seis a nueve seis manzanas
por cada nueve naranjas y ahora donde
tenemos naranjas manzanas decimos nueve
a 69 naranjas para cada seis manzanas o
podemos decir que para cada tres
naranjas tenemos exactamente dos
manzanas hasta el próximo vídeo